es una declaración de guerra del
gobierno argentino contra las bandas
criminales en la ciudad de Rosario con
el envío de 1400 tropas tras una oleada
de inseguridad de violencia generada por
las redes de narcotráfico hemos traído
fuerzas federales lo suficientemente
importante como para actuar en cada uno
de los lugares porque hemos venido a
hacer eso a trabajar sin sin destajo y
sin ningún tipo de cortapisas para
llegar al fondo de la cuestión su
objetivo rastrear los barrios y allanar
los domicilios que sean necesarios para
acabar con las estructuras criminales
si bien el problema de la violencia en
Rosario viene de largo todo escaló con
el asesinato de un niño de 11 años
máximo Jerez en medio de un fuego
cruzado en el barrio de Los Pumas
causando indignación entre los vecinos
que se sienten desprotegidos y exigen
acción del gobierno ahora la madre de
Máximo solo pide una cosa que no le
vuelva a pasar algo así a ningún otro
niño del barrio
Estamos protegidos locos
vamos loco no queremos máximo
los familiares y amigos de la víctima
intentaron tomarse la justicia por su
mano irrumpieron en la casa del supuesto
narcotraficante responsable acusando la
falta de acción gubernamental en lo que
según reconoció el propio Ministerio de
seguridad es una zona controlada por las
bandas ilegales situación tras la que el
mismo presidente Alberto Fernández
prometió actuar
Vamos a ponerle fin a la violencia
criminal de sicarios mercaderes de la
muerte en lo que va de 2023 al menos 65
personas han muerto en medio de tiroteos
en Rosario en una guerra entre bandas
por el control de los puntos de venta de
droga que afecta a los más pobres y a la
que ahora el gobierno quiere poner fin